guten abend erste mir die frage die wir
natürlich jeweils allererstes stellen
müssen wie sehr haben sie sich gefreut
als das ergebnis dann feststand und joe
biden der next president elect geworden
ist eine serie ich habe mit meiner frau
meinen kindern schon etwas gefeiert und
jetzt bin ich hier draußen bin dann
genehmige ich mir mal ihr schuss bier um
das auch tatsächlich entsprechend zu
begießen
meine mitarbeiter schule angerufen alle
freuen sich hier als ob wir quasi mit
gewählt hätten oder bürger die usa wären
denn die präsidentschaftswahl in den usa
sind wahlen die weit über die usa hinweg
bedeutung haben die usa als größte
volkswirtschaft wenn die sich
entscheidet beim klimaschutz ernst zu
machen dann ist das der ansage auch für
den rest der welt und umgekehrt und
rammt wenn sie eben eine ansage machen
nach uns die sintflut ist mir egal was
mit der welt meiner kinder passiert auch
sei ich werde reich dann ist es auch
eine ansage für den rest der welt der
schwer zu korrigieren ist insofern freue
ich mich sehr ich habe gleich mal mein
bag drop auf twitter geändert blau
eingefärbt comeback die amerikaner sind
zurück in der zivilisation die sie
selber mit aufgebaut haben wir wollen
wir nicht vergessen
im zweiten weltkrieg waren das
amerikanische soldaten die mit dazu
beigetragen haben dass der hitler
faschismus besiegt wurde
umso brutaler war es um so widerlich
erfahren ist und so herr zerbrechen da
fand ich es wie trank sich geäußert hat
der amerikanische soldaten die ihr leben
verloren hatte haben in der welt für den
einsatz für ihre werte deshalb bin ich
froh dass jetzt ein präsident an die
macht kommt mit dem wir über all diese
fragen wieder unter partnern reden
können mit denen wir gleiche werte zeit
von demokrat zu demokrat von menschen
die an gewaltenteilung pressefreiheit
respekt würde anstand glauben zu anderen
also sie bewies das ganze mit mir viel
freude dort bei ihnen und ihren kollegen
wir haben jetzt gerade auch die
stellungsnahme von angela merkel gesehen
und gelesen und
unsere kollegin patricia driese den
vergleich gemacht dass das ganze 2016
nicht ganz so euphorisch klang
glauben sie das ist jetzt ein versehen
gewesen oder will angela merkel zeigen
sie freut sich tatsächlich jetzt das
nicht donald trump noch einmal vier
jahre präsident des sondern der demokrat
joe biden jetzt das amt übernimmt
naja sie ist glauben menschen insofern
reagiert sie so wie die meisten menschen
bei uns im land dass sie sich darüber
mit schwamm bürste sie arbeiten wie das
halt so ist da kann ich nur sagen augen
auf bei der berufswahl das ist eben
manchmal so dass man dann mit leuten
zusammenarbeiten muss die nicht so
angenehm sind aber danach zahlten
unterschied
wir haben solche leute in ungarn wir
haben sie in polen wir haben sie in der
türkei aber in washington in der
herzkammer der demokratie im weißen aus
jemanden zu sitzen
der mit demokratie nichts anfangen kann
niemand schauen sich den tweet vom sohn
ein totaler krieg
das kennen wir in deutschland diese
sprache schauen sich die reaktion von
scham band der sie einfach weigert das
wahlergebnis zu akzeptieren und von
manipulation spricht die völlig haltlos
sind also selbst sein haussender fox die
muss geht da nicht mit jetzt hoffe ich
dass die beiden präsidentschaft dazu
beiträgt dass zumindest teile der
republikaner wieder aufersteht aus
diesem wahnsinn des trabis muss und
wieder zur republikanischen partei dazu
dass man partner hatten partner wie in
europa denn die republikanische partei
sie ein faktor der bleiben wird aber
natürlich auch innerhalb der usa beiden
ansprechpartner bekommt bei den
republikanern mit dem vernünftig reden
kann über putin über die gefahren in der
welt wenn ich das noch dazu sagen darf
nicht unser außenminister was gehört er
sollte ja was positiv versagen zur
außenpolitik ich habe ja letztes war
schon gesagt als ich bei ihnen der
sendung gar nicht bleibt dabei ich kann
darin nichts positives entdecken dass er
trank und seine administration sich mit
den taliban in afghanistan gut
verstanden das kann ich gut verstehen
wenn ich sage ich meistens säkulare
muslime
ich finde es keine gute nachricht dass
wir jetzt den taliban den roten teppich
ausrollen
wir sehen ja in afghanistan was die da
machen wie die menschen nach wie vor ins
jenseits befördern bombenlegen und so
weiter es verstehe ich schon gut dass
die ganzen diktatoren in der welt die
verbrecher in der welt jetzt nicht
glücklich sind die werden heute abend
garantiert kein bier trinken während
feuer haben ich kann mir vorstellen wie
es herrn erdogan geht
er wird wahrscheinlich sich überlegen ob
wir demnächst ist ich hoffe es müssen
wir doch noch einmal über donald trump
sprechen er sagt jetzt weiterhin er will
diesen sieg nicht anerkennen und was tut
er spielt einfach golf was glauben sie
wie geht es weiter mit donald trump also
ich glaube dadurch dass jetzt die
republikanische partei und das
establishment sich nicht hinter tram
gestellt hat sich allerdings auch nicht
offen distanziert hat das zeigt wie viel
heute leider am start ist
wird es da sehr einsam um ihn die frage
ist jetzt wer sagt ziehen ist es seine
tochter sind irgendwelche leute in
seinem apparat die noch verblieben sie
in dem einfach sagen was da draußen
gerade los ist dass sich auch seine
eigene partei von ihnen zunehmend
absetzt und das ist eine frage der zeit
darunter nicht herumkommen ich glaube
nicht dass wir bilder sehen werden dass
die polizei in handschellen aus dem
weißen haus führen wird dazu wird es
wohl nicht kommen das wird dann schon
noch rechtzeitig einsehen erwarten sie
ist auch klar der tramp ismus wird
bleiben die leute die ihn gewählt haben
in nichts nach der zahl darunter einige
die das erzeugt was er sagt tatsächlich
glauben
den wird man rechnen müssen und dass
eine hypothek für die künftige
präsidentschaft beiden für uns enthält
ist auch eine lehre in europa und in
deutschland nämlich zu schauen wie wir
sorgen können dass wir solche
verhältnisse nicht bekommt eine solch
gespaltene gesellschaft wohnteil sich
innerlich ab wendet von der
parlamentarischen demokratie im prinzip
alles das was demokratie ausmacht die
regelbasierte regelbasierte miteinander
ausverhandeln von mehrheit von
minderheit des aufkündigt es darf uns
hier nicht passieren
hast du mir sagen der tramp ismus wird
bleiben gleichzeitig gibt es bereits
spekulationen darüber ob donald trump
jetzt mal vier jahre opposition machen
könnte wenn er denn das weiße haus
freiwillig
oder dann möglicherweise noch einmal
antritt können sie sich vorstellen dass
donald trump noch nicht genug hat und
ist wieder versuchen wird ich würde zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt weder das eine noch
das andere ausschließen viel hängt davon
ab wie die republikanische partei sich
positioniert darf nicht vergessen einige
von denen die jetzt gewählt sind beides
im sinn der hut als auch im
repräsentantenhaus verdanken die
tatsache dass sie gewählt sind
donald trump seine politik hat sie dahin
befördert wo sie sind und ob sie sich
jetzt von ihm absetzen werden oder er
schauen werden dass die unterführung von
trump und dem ganzen apparat trump hängt
daran basteln den zwei jahren bei den
zwischenwahlen wir dürfen nicht
vergessen in amerika wird alle zwei
jahre gewählt also zwei jahren bei den
zwischenwahlen wenn ein drittel der
senatssitze neu vergeben wird und das
gesamte repräsentantenhaus noch einmal
gewählt wird dann normal quasi beiden
antike an die kette zu legen dafür zu
sorgen dass er seine wahlversprechen
umsetzen kann weil er keine
parlamentarischen mehrheiten hat das
wird man sehen ich würde prognostizieren
dass es in die richtung geht ob das dann
mit tram bus oder mit jemand anders ist
das sei mal dahin gestellt aber die
ideologie für die trump steht die es
nicht mehr
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren